now usually there's people sitting on
the bridges selling water asking for
money
a change could be in the works to stop
people from just hanging out on the
pedestrian overpasses on the strip it is
a plan one county commissioner says will
make the strip even safer good evening
to you on this friday thanks for joining
us at six i'm brian loftis and i'm
vanessa murphy filling in for denise
this evening that change would be
defining those overpasses as crosswalks
joe moeller is on one overpass at
flamingo and las vegas boulevard with
what this all means hi joe
hey there vanessa you know when you come
out on the strip and you walk these
bridges sometimes there's people selling
water sometimes people performing music
well there could be a plan on the table
here soon that could change what can
exactly happen on these bridges
people from the
hotels tell me they hear me down there
and they like it on this busy friday
jose kukanala is performing for all the
visitors
he either finds a corner that works or
performs on the pedestrian overpasses
for now how are you going to stop people
from making a living a potential change
could be on the table soon to officially
define these overpasses as crosswalks
that means no more performing or
loitering they would be used for walking
and that is it i feel sorry for people
that really depend on this this is they
live in this and they can't get a job
nowhere else so they do this tuesday
county commissioners will take a look at
a presentation on the idea you can't
stay in a crosswalk so we're trying to
come up with a way that we can legally
make sure people move county
commissioner tick sigerblum says it's
all about public safety especially after
a recent deadly stabbing of a visiting
off-duty police officer just weeks ago
on a bridge we just can't tolerate
people out there committing sex acts and
shooting people and shooting drugs it's
just unacceptable from playing music to
selling items or asking for money
visitors say they have noticed it i
don't want to feel threatened when i'm
walking across the ridge lisa worgerland
is visiting from canada she understands
the idea but says it could create other
issues it probably is a good idea to
have it just as a crosswalk but then you
have to also
probably give an option for these people
because they're just going to move
to somewhere else
back out here live on this busy friday
afternoon sucker bloom says the
commissioners will be taking a look at a
presentation about this possible change
at the next meeting coming up on tuesday
and then after that an ordinance could
be made reporting live on the strip this
evening joe muller live local now